hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar drug
stability testing 101
how to ensure your pharmaceutical
testing can handle the heat
i am michelle ashton of labyrinth and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
and brought to you by thermo fisher
scientific to learn more
visit thermofisher.com chambers
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also submit any technical issues here as
well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers
free continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education credit
window
at the bottom of your screen to obtain
your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
felicia pierre-louis
senior product manager at thermo fisher
scientific
and bernie schwartz commercial manager
at thermal fisher scientific
our speakers now begin their
presentations
[Music]
thank you michelle and thank all of you
for joining us today
we're looking forward to providing an
overview on drug stability
before we get started bernie and i will
introduce ourselves
as michelle mentioned i'm a senior
product manager at thermal fisher
scientific
i've been at the company for about three
years now and i lead the development
and innovation strategy for
environmental chambers and incubators
it's been such a joy working with the
researchers that use these chambers and
incubators to make their impact on the
world
bernie
thank you felicia and thank you everyone
for joining
hello from music city nashville
tennessee
again my name is bernie schwartz i'm a
commercial manager for thermo fisher
scientific
my passion is working with the research
community to identify the products
and solutions to help solve the complex
analytical analytical problems with 30
with over 30 years in the industry i've
spent most of my time
in labs first working on the technical
side
where i saw firsthand how equipment fits
into the workflows
to now where i support and promote
innovative products
i look forward to talking to you later
in this presentation
felicia will now take us
thank you bernie yes today we'll be
reviewing why stability testing is
important
and the regulations that dictate
stability testing
there are testing parameters that guide
stability testing
as well as methods of which force
degradation is won
we'll talk briefly about how drug
stability testing provides data
that can be extrapolated to different
climate zones
then we'll end with bernie on a
discussion about technology that
facilitates successful drug stability
testing
[Music]
let's get started off on the same page
first of all
drug stability testing is the process of
testing the quality of a drug
either drug substance or drug products
over time and under different
environmental factors like
temperature humidity ph and light
this testing process is important
because drugs are produced with a
variety of active pharmaceutical
ingredients
apis and inactive ingredients
depending on the drug formulation the
drug will have different rates of
solubility
permeability and stability which then
impacts its quality
safety and efficacy over time
stability testing evaluates the physical
chemical
and microbiological changes in
pharmaceutical products over time from
environmental factors
it's critical to understand a
pharmaceutical product's performance
in order to formulate and sustain a high
quality product
each of these aspects can potentially
impact the efficiency
and integrity of a product which may
eventually impact the consumer's health
for example aspirin tablets are supposed
to be stored at room temperature and in
a dry
place to preserve its efficiency and
shelf life
if store is stored incorrectly like a
medicine cabinet
in a humid bathroom it will degrade and
produce acidic acid
which gives off gives off a vinegar-like
smell
the aspirin is now less effective and it
may irritate the consumer
[Music]
stability testing is used in three ways
related to pharmaceutical products
first it's used for drugs ability
testing
to determine a stability profile
necessary to both
prove a drug formulation's performance
and safety
then the product is tested to determine
a reliable shelf life and recommended
storage conditions
further package testing can confirm
appropriate packaging
and container closures to support safe
distribution to consumers
and storage until the shelf life
expiration date
as pharmaceutical manufacturers test
their products there are compliance
regulations that must be followed
these manufacturers not only perform the
necessary stability
shelf life and package testing to
distribute a safe and effective product
they must also provide evidence of
proper testing protocols and procedures
to support
products manufacturing through
distribution and onto consumer
consumption
and each country has a health authority
which is responsible to enforce the
rules regulations
and issue guidelines to regulate drug
development
as well as licensing registration
manufacturing marketing and labeling of
pharmaceutical products pharmaceuticals
are the most highly regulated industry
in the world
accordingly the international council
for harmonization
ich for short brings together
international regulatory authorities
and the pharmaceutical industry to
ensure the safety quality and efficacy
of medicines
and medical devices globally
accordingly the ich has two main
guidelines for stability testing of
pharmaceutical products and development
q a contains the overall guidelines for
stability testing around the effects of
temperature and humidity
including batch selection testing
frequency and storage conditions
while q1b contains guidelines for how
light should be tested in addition to
the parameters mentioned in q a
other guidelines provided by ich deo
stability testing related to
pharmaceutical products
that have been developed and are being
submitted for registration
stability testing is based around four
key
parameters temperature light
humidity and ph that affect the
stability of a drug
on the next four slides we're going to
look at each testing parameter
temperature is one of the most crucial
factors in drug stability
all pharmaceutical products must be
stored at suitable temperatures to avoid
thermal acceleration of decomposition
resulting in physical chemical or
microbiological changes
in pharmaceutical products for example
products exposed to
too high or too low temperatures may
lose
active ingredient content or alter its
performance
[Music]
a large number of pharmaceutical
products are sensitive to light
light can create chemical changes that
decrease potency
or efficacy the rate of photochemical
reaction or
photolysis depends on the intensity of
the radiation source and transmission
characteristics of the packaging itself
for example photo products of a drug due
to light exposure
can be harmful to the consumer and cause
phototoxic
photo out allergic or photosensitization
reactions upon administration
[Music]
humidity can have a powerful effect on
the physical
chemical or microbiological aspects in
pharmaceutical products
for example low humidity can have
physical and chemical effects that cause
products to dry and stick together while
high humidity can offer a breeding
ground for viruses
bacteria molds etc that impact the
microbiological stability of a product
[Music]
ph is an important factor in the
stability
stabilization of a drug substance
the major degradation pathways include
hydrolysis
hydrolysis is generally acid or base
catalyzed and can be measured through ph
testing
ph profiles help determine the best
buffer to use
for example during drug formulation to
maintain drug stability
[Music]
for segregation is a type of stress
study
that is completed in different ph
solutions in the presence of oxygen
and light and at elevated temperatures
and humidity levels to determine the
stability of the drug substance
after forced segregation studies
accelerated stability
testing is completed to determine shelf
life
and storage conditions for early
toxicological and clinical study
long-term stability studies will also be
initiated on both the active
pharmaceutical ingredient
and the drug product with stored at
accelerated and long-term conditions
these studies reduce the need to run
tests in different regions of the world
to test
different climate zones
drugs are most often developed under
time pressure and limited resources
yet manufacturers are responsible for
evaluating drug
products for storage shipment and shelf
life in every climate zone
the drug will be distributed in an ideal
world the team would have unlimited time
and a large supply of api material
for the team to run tests that explore
various drug forms and delivery systems
for consumers
fortunately for segregation studies can
simulate multiple climate zones from one
site
[Music]
the world health organization and ich
have divided the world into five climate
zones
and these zones have specific
temperature and relative humidity
ranges that guide stability testing and
must tap into qualifying pharmaceutical
drug for a given zone
for example zone 1 is made of temperate
zones including parts of north america
and
asia while zone 5 is on the opposite
scale with
hot and very humid conditions and
includes parts of south
south america africa and asia
[Music]
stability testing can be performed from
two types of technology
environmental chambers or light chambers
depending on the forced segregation
protocol required
one or the other may be the best fit the
environmental chamber contains an
inner chamber that controls temperature
and humidity and can be run according to
a program
while light chambers can control light
in addition to the temperature and
humidity
and this is particularly necessary for
comprehensive package testing
throughout this presentation i covered
several variables and testing parameters
that need to be considered to formulate
and ultimately deliver a safe and
effective pharmaceutical product
a reliable chamber can provide five main
benefits
first accurate data is of utmost
importance throughout the drug
development process
second a reliable chamber can facilitate
testing that accounts for different
climate zones using just one piece of
technology
which increases productivity during
drugs development
third and fourth to facilitate an
efficient process
an easy-to-use chamber that has safety
protocols to protect the user
ensures that testing is completed safely
quickly and easily
lastly a chamber that can be used for
several modes of testing
as well as configured exactly to one's
protocol and batch sizing
further supports a productive process
now i'll hand off to bernie to introduce
thermal scientific format environmental
and light chambers
[Music]
thank you felicia for that informative
discussion on drug stability
when thinking about this application it
is important to consider a chamber that
meets certain requirements
namely type parameters and repeatable
performance
that is required to validate the
efficacy stability
and life of a drug product an important
aspect
of any testing is temperature uniformity
directed air flow would minimize the
risk of product desiccation
and loss along with wasted time and
additional cost
due to the poor temperature uniformity
and recovery
additionally the air flow system
should ensure airflow uniformity
regardless of the sample load your
particular testing
likely includes parameters felicia
mentioned
when considering a chamber think about
your testing protocols
and compliance needs you may need
you may be looking for a controlled
temperature and humidity
or a wide temp range for storage
or incubation elevated temperature
testing
or life stability testing to meet the
ich guidelines for photo stability
under q1b guidelines
speaking of the light applications a
typical light process
is to expose the sample to x lux hours
and watts per square meter of uv light
some safety and control features to look
for are
temperature extremes and automatic light
shut off
to help visualize the animation
that allows for viewing of the thermo
fisher scientific
light chamber platform let's take a look
this view shows the uh 29 cubic foot
chamber
with its rugged uh solid construction
helps with reliability 18 gauge cold
rolled steel exterior
which will resist scratching stainless
steel interiors
and a foam insulation to help with
uniformity and strength
this tool will allow for 360 degree
rotation
of the instrument
the business end if you will is at the
top of the unit
this will give the user full access to
the chamber
all units are incorporate
a temperature watt low controller this
is a an industry standard very tight
control parameters
along with over temperature and under
temperature
dial in parameters units that
incorporate a humidity function will
also have an additional wattle
controller
very specific to the humidity of that
particular unit
additionally units that have a light
component like this unit here
will also have controls for the light
function
within the chamber itself other switch
compressor system for refrigeration
defrost and humidity systems
let's take a look at the inside of the
chamber
this will give you a good idea on how
the chamber looks with the light
components
installed so this unit the 29 cubic foot
incorporates three of the light
cassettes
i mentioned earlier each of those
cassettes contains seven bulbs that
would be unique for the particular light
application
additionally the stainless steel shelves
as depicted here will allow the user for
distance from the lights for their
particular applications
the standard 39 cubic foot unit would
have the three light cassettes
as we see here we can easily
pull out the lights as shown here and
adjust the lights along the side walls
with the rails that that are
incorporated with the system itself
additionally the stainless steel shelves
depicted here
can achieve the same thing you can move
the shelves up or down depending upon
your application
speaking of the shelves we have other
other shelving operations
uh other shelving options that would
include perforated shelves
and reinforced shelves for apparatus
that you might want to place inside the
unit that is beyond the weight of the
standard shelf
additionally we have found over time
that
a lot of applications require
external probes we've incorporated a two
inch
access port on every single unit that is
uh
is produced regardless of its function
i'd like to talk
here about the addition of the ac
what we call the smart view sensors
where it's it's probe specific
for uh for any application you can you
can have it for temperature humidity
or with the size of the port that you
could
pass through as many umbilicals as you
need to for for your testing convenience
let's go back to the
presentation now and answer some of your
questions
while we're doing that the you can ask
for a tour
uh at any point in time and we'll be
happy to take you through on a more
in-depth level
for uh the instrument
michelle do we have any questions oh we
do
thank you felicia and bernie for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
all right we have lots of great
questions coming in let's go ahead and
start with this first question this
one's for you felicia
what effect does humidity have on drugs
thanks michelle sure i touched on this
one
a bit quickly in the presentation until
humidity
introduces moisture into a drug or
pharmaceutical product however you may
want to call it
which affects the stability and
especially depending on the dosage form
so for example tablets and capsules
degrade when exposed to high moisture
and loses its effectiveness
okay great thank you looks like we have
another question for you here felicia
what changes to drugs what a stability
profile
provide what changes to drugs will
disability profile provide
sure thing a drug stability profile
summarizes the stability results
for a given drug under different
temperature humidity
light and peach
and the results of these studies inform
what packaging and container closure
system
one might use as well as inform the
recommended storage guidelines
an example of this is a light-sensitive
pharmaceutical product may be packaged
in a light blocking amber bottle
or if the dosage form is a tablet
that may be coated with a film
so those so those are the types of
things that a stability profile would be
able to
let you know and what changes you might
want to make as a result
thank you felicia all right this next
question is for you bernie
do i need a water source inside my lab
to operate an environmental chamber
oh i think you might be muted you want
to go ahead and unmute
there we go oh sorry i thought i i
thought i unmuted
uh yeah very good question uh
especially with the chambers that offer
humidity
uh as there is a high consumption
any gravity that fed by a car boy
and we can help work
okay great thank you questions
all right felicia this next question is
for you
how do i get started with designing my
stability test
oh this is an exciting question great
though there
there's they're different there are many
different important
factors that you one should consider
when designing and conducting stability
studies and
so this would depend on the drug or
substance the direct substance or the
product being tested
right what you want to make sure of is
that your
program confirms the assay purity
and impurities over time and under
different environmental factors
so that means that the design will vary
depending on
what you're looking for and whether or
not you're testing a drug substance or a
product
um one thing to make sure is accounted
for especially
which gets missed is the amount of
material required
ahead of time and then going above this
to
have at least 25 percent more backup
material and this
is important because it can be tricky
trying to figure out
the timing availability and the quantity
so making sure that
some time has been taken to figure out
the amount of material needed and then
bumping that up to account for some
backup is one of
a good strategy around making sure one
is prepared
for this stability testing but also
should be considered when designing
their tests too
all right wonderful thank you okay
bernie this next question is for you
what are my options for counteracting
the condensate discharge generated
within the chamber
michelle we actually offer three options
to mitigate the condensate one
which is the the best option that i i
think of
is having a drain close to the unit
there's no uh back pressure so this
would drain right into your existing
drain at the facility
if that's not available we also offer a
condensate evaporator
where the condensate would evaporate as
it
uh as it hits the evaporation mechanism
if that's not
acceptable then we also offer a pump
that will pump the condensate to a drain
nearby
uh my personal experience is that pump
is very powerful
and will will actually pump the water
for a pretty good distance
thank you bernie all right felicia this
question's for you
are there different testing
considerations for biologics
sure sure yes um so yes there is
though the considerations are the same
as for a normal drug substance or drug
products but since biologics are more of
a kind of
next generation type product disability
testing
is a little bit more involved than other
well-characterized products and
specifically ich q5c would be a good
guideline to look
up because there are some guidelines
there that are specifically for biologic
so i would direct you
to look that up and it's available
online
all right clay thank you
all right bernie it looks like this
question might be for you as well
um what comes standard with the purchase
of a light chamber
another great question michelle so the
the the way to think about it is
capabilities
the the standard unit for light
capabilities
comes with the ability to not only
run the light aspect of the chambers but
also
run all the other aspects of the chamber
and what i mean by that
is that with the capabilities to
install the like cassettes that i showed
on the uh the 3d tour each of those
light cassettes then would be purchased
individually
while the 29 cubic foot unit can
accommodate
three light cassettes you may not
require that for your application so you
would only need to
balance of the chamber to use for for
another purpose so again the unit comes
with the light capabilities
and the light cassettes for your
particular application
are purchased separately good question
thank you bernie we have another
question for you here
do these chambers work for products
other than drugs for example like
foods or plants or soils etc
wow that's another great question
michelle and and yes absolutely
so that leads to the versatility of the
instrument that i just mentioned
where the uh the light cassettes the
light frequency of those cassettes
are four different applications either
for
insect studies plant growth
stability under q1b so a very versatile
system
uh you can purchase one or more of the
cassettes and use for varying
applications
time but you could run them in
succession
good question
okay felicia i have another question for
you here
can you expose your drugs product to
different testing conditions in your
equipment at the same time
and how do you control the different
conditions
sure can you i'll i'll break it down
part by part
can you expose your drug products to
different testing conditions in your
equipment
at the same time i know
the the the chamber at least my my
direct reference is the environmental
chambers
that i manage and on the market they
tend to be one
inner chamber and so within this inner
chamber
the conditions are the same throughout
their uniform in fact
one of the things you you should look
for in a reliable environmental chamber
is one that has
very accurate temperature uniformity and
stability throughout the chamber
and so that you can make sure that every
area of that chamber is being exposed
the exact same thing and so with that
you can only
um expose your drug product to the same
thing
at the same time you can't run any
parallel uh operations there
and so how do you control the different
conditions well
there are controls that have to do with
your temperature
our range is from 0 to 60 which is the
typical
stability testing range and you can
control temperature
as well as your humidity which can range
depending
on uh depending on the requirements that
you have
all of which you would control from
directly on your machine and you'd run
over
a specific amount of time
for your per your stability program that
you've put together
right the only thing that i would add to
what felicia said
is that if like i just mentioned if you
had
one cassette like cassette in the
chamber
you could run a light test at that level
of the chamber
and then you could run some other static
tests
on on other shelves how uh
atmosphere inside the chamber the
conditions inside the chamber would
be the same ever with respect
[Music]
all right great thank you both
okay this next question is for you
felicia does the stability of the drug
get affected by the high temperatures
in developing countries and what action
can you take when there is an electrical
outage
yes that's a good kind of real life
practical question when especially when
running the stability testing
in that developing country so to address
the first part of your question
how does high temperature affect the
pharmaceutical product it can have a
variety
of effects which is why it's such a key
thing to monitor
it can have physical effects where
especially depending on the dosage form
it may have some
physical impacts uh there may be
chemical
and chemical effects as well as
microbiological so depending
on the amount of time that that
that drug has been exposed to the high
temperature
you may see some growth uh some some
kind of
viral or it really depends on what
what it's been exposed to and so another
reason why these stability testing
profiles are really important in making
sure that one is accounting for
all the different factors that one's
drug may be
exposed to and so what happens when
there's an electrical outage well
that study should be run all over again
unfortunately
there are some products where the the
chamber will restart for you and will
let you know
and so you'll want to look for a chamber
that provides some kind of alert to you
that the
temperature inside your your
environmental chamber for example has
deviated
um because what you want to make sure
first and foremost is that you're
exposing
that drug to the same temperature same
humidity
overall same environmental factors
throughout the specified amount of time
that you would set from the beginning so
ideally you should start over
thanks for that question
okay great all right bernie this next
question is for you
what are the feed water requirements for
environmental chambers
well that's another good question
michelle we had talked earlier about
water sources uh
it uses uh active humidity
and so we don't make a presumption about
the condition
of tap water uh so the water purity
needs to have a resistance range from 50
to 1 mega all
typically that would be you know you
have di water at your facility
water that would be preferable for this
system a lot of institutions have a di
line
a pressurized line that would help uh
with the feed and we can provide the
documentation to anyone who needs that
thank you
okay wonderful all right felicia this
one's for you
is there a difference between stress
testing
for segregation testing and accelerated
testing
[Music]
yes yes there was uh well for
segregation
well sorry there isn't a difference um
they're they're
the force declaration is also known as
stress testing but there's different
types of stress testing
which can include accelerated
intermediate and long-term testing
thanks for that question great
okay next question is for bernie can i
run
the light chamber without light using
only temperature
and humidity
yes absolutely that is
this instrument and i often talk to
folks about the type of chamber that
they're looking for
and if you have any protocols where
you're going to run light either now or
later on
have the unit that has the capability
and then
you could run the chamber temperature
humidity without the light
cassettes in there and then later on
when you have light protocols
uh that you need to meet then you could
add
[Music]
all right this next question is for you
felicia um and it's why would you use
a photo chamber
yes why would you use a photo chamber
i'm assuming why would you use a photo
chamber instead of a stability chamber
and the key reason would be that the
light chamber has
light cassettes as bernie has talked
about maybe you could add some more
to my answer bernie the the stability
chamber
can't be used for the light stability or
the photostability testing that one
might use
and that can be a key study
for your your drug because of the fact
that packaging
can affect the the storage
um the shelf life and that will actually
ultimately affect the shelf life of the
drug
and so your packaging would ideally
support
that shelf life and would support it for
as long as
that recommended shelf life is and so to
be able to run
a photo stability testing on that would
make sure that
light is a factor that's been accounted
for in that packaging
and also in that shelf life
determination
anything fast yeah that's that's correct
uh
no you know the only thing is we you
know to bring it home to everyone we all
have you know medicines in our uh in our
cabinets and if you look at the
the uh opaqueness of the uh
the vessels whether either for ourselves
or our pets those have all been tested
for photostability of those drugs within
those containers
all right looks like we have time for
one more one last question here
this is for bernie is how do i request a
demo
[Applause]
well that's that's excellent the best
way
is via your local
you can go to the website uh www
dot backslash
chambers and select con the contact
us button and you fill out the form and
that will get you connected with the
product specialist
and as i mentioned earlier i'm involved
in a lot of the
thank you michelle
you're very welcome um so i want to
thank you both felicia and bernie for
your time today
do you have any final comments for our
audience before we go
sure thing thank you michelle and thank
you lab roots for this platform bernie
and i have really enjoyed sharing our
knowledge here today
on drug stability tests and testing
technology
if you have any questions please feel
free again to visit us at
thermalfresher.com
chambers and select the contact us
button
where you'll see a form and you'll get
connected directly to a product
specialist
and thank you for your time and i hope
that you've learned something today here
about drug stability testing
yes i echo what felicia just said thank
you very much
for your time great questions
and we're happy to assist you in any way
we can
wonderful well thank you again felicia
and bernie for your time today and for
your important research we would also
like to thank
labruz and our sponsor thermo fisher
scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions this
webcast can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye